I'm not worried about what people how
much sleep they get I'm worried about
what they do while they're awake okay
but the two things are connected because
if you wake up fully recharged it means
you wake up ready to take on the world
you know that feeling you wake up and
you say come on bring it on it doesn't
matter how many obstacles challenges
setbacks said I prefer those things okay
perfect well you know Travis is a friend
of yours I just joined the board of uber
Travis has a little bit of that it's
like he may be dealing with 30 crises at
the same time he eats for lunch and what
happens and here's the kid who just put
something on your facebook yes sir that
I love which is it sounds completely
just busyness that's it it's not life
and death the people who have a hard
time are the people who basically make
it to importance its respective is
everything and that's really what stoic
philosophers believe do you know who is
my greatest here rather than yo Gary yes
I think I'll pick a dead person
he's Marcus Aurelius and tell you why he
was the emperor of Rome pretty big job
he agreed like right in the arena dearly
with invasions plagues everything and
literally nothing ever got to him he
wrote a book about it called meditations
that I have by my bed and every time I'm
beginning to get anxious about something
or worried or I look at that book and
the fact is that he considered life as
though everything that happened was a
hidden blessing I creator said I don't
know why I don't know how but another
favorite of mine Rumi you know the
Persian poet he said live life as though
everything is rigged in your favor
whatever happens I mean for me some of
my biggest heartbreaks led to my biggest
moments of joy and happiness and success
blah blah I believe in that stuff so
much